[Music]
hey this Steve want job with Collider
and I'm in the Kia Telluride supper
suite at Sundance with everyone behind
falling I want to start by saying
congrats on the movie to everyone thank
you so I'm gonna jump right on in with
Viggo as the the person behind this this
is your feature debut that's right what
was it something that you had been
thinking about doing for a long time
what was it about you know what I mean
like when did you decide I want to make
a movie well not just my feature debuts
but just my directing you haven't
directed a short or anything but now I'd
wanted to try the directing a long time
ago I mean I have several scripts this
was the first one I was able to get put
together and it was the right time and I
found the right group of people and
luckily we were able to to complete it I
hate asking the generic question but
everyone watching will have not seen the
movie yet so could you sort of talk a
little bit about what it's about at its
center as the character played by Lance
Henriksen Willis the father the
patriarch of the family a complicated
person and it's a sent at the heart of
it it's a story about the relationship
between a father and son I play his son
Ferrier plays Willis in in the past
indifferent in the 60s and in the 70s
Hannah is Willis's wife Gwen my mom and
Jill is Willis is second wife and Terry
plays Eric who is my partner we live in
California my dad lives on a farm in
rural northeastern the United States and
he's quite different than we are and our
family model mine growing up was a lot
different and so there's a lot of mmm I
guess polarization within the family of
conflict and Willis's in the early
stages of dementia so he can't live on
the farm by himself anymore he's
acknowledged that it comes out to
California we're gonna try and find him
to live near me and my sister who's
played by Laura Linney and when he gets
there he goes what house what are you
talking about he's completely forgotten
or denies that he's gonna move anywhere
off the farm so it's that's part of it
that's how it starts I want to jump in
one Mike I think my favorite part of the
film is the fact that all too often and
in every movie that's made you have the
first three quarters of the film there's
a character who's a real [ __ ] and
then in the final bit and then in the
and then in the final bit they do that
transformation so it's all forgiven
everyone is fine your character from
frame one basically till the end is who
he is
can you sort of talk about that aspect
of the film he's trying to make up for
it by wearing that shirt but I don't
know if it's working I was trying to
lighten the whole thing you know hey
look you know when you when you get
toward the backdoor of life right
certain aspects of your you know a
mental availability start slipping so
you can't keep track what you said
what's tomorrow gonna bring you don't
live that where you're living in kind of
the moment and it's not kind of but
you're living in the moment and my son
is pushing me to fix me and anytime
somebody tries to fix me I get really
upset because I feel like I'm perfect
and I'm not kidding I feel like I know
my life I have a false a perfect phone
call yes and I have I have three horses
that I love and I have the seasons and I
don't look in mirrors I watch TV but I
don't look in a mirror you know I don't
know where I'm at and all of those
especially this character because he's
got some damage go on you know in life
will damage you it's not easy sure what
if you don't mind just address the fact
that the character is who he is the
whole movie you know like that aspect of
the film that it's not some Hollywood
you know focus group you're selling
Disney it's not a Disney movie I'm sorry
does that bad no it's not it's not a
family movie it is what it is for
everyone here
I would imagine making this was both
challenging and fun and every emotion
Under the Sun but for each of you if you
could share maybe like a memory from the
making of the film like something that
really stuck stuck out whether maybe
Viggo's working with you know what I
mean like something that do did you want
to start down there I will start yeah I
mean the whole experience was special
just because of you know
Viggo's words and his his writing and
there were so many special moments but I
gotta say my favorite day was probably
when David Cronenberg was on set he
played a proctologist so I was lucky
enough to be there for that day and Vigo
and Lance and I and mr. Cronenberg had
some fun with a glove and some and the
jokes ensued and the crew yeah the crew
was loving it too though surprise me
that you picked that scene oh yeah of
course of course he kidding me I haven't
blazoned in my skull now but yeah that
was a really special day and to be able
to you know work with such legends yeah
yeah likewise was a very special
experience for me hard to pick one
single moment but since I have to there
was we shot a scene with Grady who plays
the younger version the youngest version
of John Figo's character and because
Grady's a child he had to leave at one
point in the night so Viggo subbed in
for Grady was one of the best acting
partners I've ever had it was hard for
you and failure to keep a straight face
I really I got his I didn't quite get
his voice right it's for actually at the
time I think for me coming here and
getting to dig into American culture and
write all those pickup trucks and
hunting and deer hunting and Viggo knows
all about that stuff so it was very
helpful me how to do it and it was just
I think the whole whole experience was
wonderful to get to work with all these
fantastic people I will have to agree
with that yeah we learned though I
learned a lot on set the first day or
maybe was the second day I remember Vigo
called me a big crunchy monster if
you'll know the scene in there in the
show I remember him saying to the little
one just look at the crunchy monster and
I was like still like Rowley you know
still in it but yeah I learned a lot I
remember we'd come away you know come
away from the set and start the monitor
and I just remember hearing Viggo
actually working with another actor and
he said um he was like it's just it's
just a change in wait that's all it is
and I was like I love that it was like
the acting moment was just this shift in
weight I was like I'm really happy when
I met him he's the younger me and I did
look good that's why I approve feeling
pretty good yeah I felt pretty good and
then they had to see me like rave about
something and and I thought I hope they
still like me
they like you with or without that shirt
I'm sure I do two men as far as
something that stands out there's so
many moments I mean in a general sense
it was all the the presents that you
guys brought and the kids in the movie
you know surprises like I wouldn't have
expected the line to come out that way
or or someone to laugh or be moved in a
certain way the reading of lines like
things that you haven't thought about
just like when you're acting and the
other actor does something oh now I I'm
really in the moment except to react to
something I didn't expect and as a
director I'd like that generally a
specific memory that I liked we were
having trouble getting permission to go
do a shot were Lance by the way the
crunchy monster she's eating toast and
she's the stepmom she's new to this
family unit and the two little kids me
as a ten-year-old and my sister as a six
year old I'm just staring at her it's
like everything the stepmom does is not
right so when she's eating toast the
toast sounds like a bomb going off and
they're like how hideous so I said she's
the crunchy monster and yeah but a
moment that I remember was there's a
scene where Lance as he does a couple
times in the movie his character well I
don't know if it was Lance or Willis but
anyway he escapes from our supervision
basically he says I'm going to the
bathroom in a restaurant and then he
doesn't never comes back he goes out the
back alley and he goes down ends up on
the beach and he spends the day there
and we're like and and he and we're
looking all over Venice California for
I'm really desperate and he walks out
fully clothed into the sea you know
smoking a cigarette and the waves are
smashing into him knocking him over and
we didn't we hadn't I don't know if I
should say this we didn't have
permission I said let's just go swimmin
and so obviously it was just me and
Lance and and we had the camera and a
hefty bag in case we fell in the water
and I'm holding the camera it's just the
three of us out in the way is
the waves have started really come in he
got knocked on his ass a couple of times
and I remember that that was a really
fun wasn't it yeah you're a trooper
you're famous for saying one more you
got another one on you it's Emmy and
well the Sun is starting to set and then
all of a sudden the whole sky was like
looking into a blazing furnace you know
it was beautiful
dark everywhere else but that boom and
so we go in and I said Viggo you better
stand behind the counter guy because
he's not gonna see the wave coming
because those waves were coming in off
of Venice Beach you know I mean it was
like really was a great moment it really
was I always have another one in me by
the way I know you you're tough
I definitely you you utter you say some
pretty nasty things and your character
is your character is pretty tough how is
it that's basically his character like
but way way worse than that that's
that's like the g-rated version of your
character the neuro version but but I am
curious what is it like how tough is it
to do that when you're playing someone
who's really like that mean and you know
what I mean and like what is it like
being in those scenes is it ever awkward
or is it you know like it must be a
little bit tough playing someone like
that it's hard it's hard to look at
people when you're attacking them
especially actors that you really like
you know you care about and and Viggo
especially I mean he's my son but I
don't know how to talk to him
I mean I'm trying to talk to him when
I'm really more commanding and demanding
and those kind of thing just to prove
that I'm healthy hmm anyway yeah but so
the answer is it has to be done it's a
little bit like doing surgery you have
to do it it's not fun it's not it's not
kind it's brutal reality is brutal and
so I just took that on sir look I know
we're at war making this movie well war
the whole thing other other characters
in this movie he takes a lot of crap for
me you know I mean and I'd look in his
eyes and it would hurt I could see it
hurt because that was the purpose I
wanted to hurt him
Lance is one of the most beautiful
gentle souls I've ever met
any time we had any like really harsh
things coming through immediately after
we cut Lance was apologetic you know it
was but everybody supported him you know
I all wanted to see him succeed and it
was a very difficult role for him to to
put on to bring to life but everybody
everybody wanted to see him win so yeah
it was it was beautiful watch
you know painful and beautiful but
that's yeah that's a slice of life it
had to be real it's very er we didn't
care each other by about 50 years no
scarier had a very subtle stuff to do
that set up the way Lance played the
character later little signs that things
weren't quite right just odd reactions
antisocial reactions like the birthday
party scene even the thing with you know
simple things like my mom asks him you
know Hannah's character says do you mind
turning the radio down a little bit and
he goes and turns it off she goes I
didn't mean turn all the way off and
he's like yeah so he's very defensive
he's not comfortable around me he's
comfortable in nature with his farm he
loves his wife why do other people have
to come visit
you know I don't think you even like
going to the store you probably get in
arguments when you go buy farm equipment
but he doesn't know how to show it so it
comes out the wrong way always but I
think he shows his love by by working
hard and putting food on the table
that's it every every time I saw you
walking in or out of that door it always
said labor it always said I'm very good
at labor I know it I'm going out and do
some more you know meaning you had that
in you when you were playing the role I
could see it and you don't know it
you're like you don't like when you
don't you never noticed it in a way he
was always exiting and entering but it
was all about labor I saw the thing that
that I really enjoyed about your
performance and I'm curious how much is
is that in every scene I really didn't
know which direction the character was
gonna go I'm like with that radio scene
for example when he shuts it off I
thought he was just gonna have a
flip-out moment you know and but it's
constantly like walking on eggshells and
could you sort of talk about that I also
went to work he left something like
making making it hard for him to you
know it shows in some way and it tries
to it gets worse and worse
you changes a lot from the zoo I don't
know how you feel about Anna or you
Bracken but Tim when I was writing it
and when you guys are playing at it I
kept thinking about the fact that
imagining what it was that it drew you
to be with him you know as a man what it
was it about him and I was thinking that
maybe it's the very thing that at first
was interesting well he's very
self-sufficient he can fix his own
tractor he does everything he knows how
to fix the electricity what he's
completely self-sufficient and strong
and very independent he's not like any
other guy in the area in that town and
that's appealing because he's like he's
strong he can take care of I mean he
wasn't sometimes he can take care of the
family can if anything goes wrong
massive snowstorm the lights go out
he'll fix it and he's he's just not like
other guys he has his own way of
thinking about stuff and that's
appealing an individual very
individualistic man a strong character
and the vet that very aspect that
attracts you over time is probably the
thing that pushes you away because you
realize well someone is that independent
it means they're not really interested
in other people and you might want to
see your friends once in a while you
might want to have a conversation with
him about something other than what's
for dinner you know
or let's go to bed you know and so the
very thing that's appealing this strong
character maybe later becomes less I
don't know I was thinking I don't know
if you guys feel that's true or no
absolutely and yeah I think that that
tension in him is what makes him
charismatic and yeah I mean it's it's um
it's flattering to be loved by a person
who isn't easy you know and but but then
of course you know as I think it's it's
a generalization but yeah as people get
older they become more ingrained in
their their characteristics become
deeper ingrained and so exactly all of
these
these things that had a little sparkle
and the charisma becomes a repellant as
they become further solidified in his
character and and then he because he
also begins to push people farther and
further away and that's what makes him
impossible to love yeah I was gonna say
you did such a great job playing Willis
that I definitely noticed when we watch
it after and watching you guys on set
work Willis did get worse he feel like
his lashing out got worse and you can
see that in the diner scene when he hits
the table and I think yeah that's kind
of even though it says in the film that
Jill loved him so much to the end I
think it was maybe yeah that little bit
too much of aggression and and like
meanness inside that she maybe couldn't
handle when she loved him so much so it
was so painful um on that note I need to
stop with you guys and I'm just gonna
say and I mean it congratulations on the
movie thank you for coming in and
talking to us huge thank you to Kia for
being an awesome sponsor and I hope the
film sells it's for sale right yes we're
looking for we're gonna be walking up
and down Main Street doesn't get buyers
I was gonna say I'm uh wish you nothing
but the best and hope it sells today
thank you thank you